الحصول على سيارتي هنا غير ممكن ، هل
يجب عليك حقًا التنزه في هذا
المطعم الموجود في جبال الألب السويسرية لمدة 173
عامًا ، وقد اجتذبت الرحلة دائمًا
المتنزهين الجائعين ، لكنها شديدة الانحدار على
ارتفاع 5000 قدم تقريبًا ، مرحبًا ومرحبًا بكم في Asher
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اسمي ميلاني وينتر وأنا
مدير المطعم طعامنا تقليدي جدًا ،
حصلنا على ستة أجبان
منتقاة أو لا كرواسون ولكن قبل أن
تصدر أي طلبات ، إليك كيفية الوصول إلى هناك
[موسيقى]
أولاً  كانتون أبنزل في
راودون وتوجه إلى فاسار أوين ثم
التلفريك ، ستقطع مسافة
تزيد عن 2000 قدم إلى جبل إيفرنوت
بمجرد أن تصل إلى هناك ، فإن أحذية المشي لمسافات طويلة سعيدة
جاهزة لمدة 15 دقيقة للمشي لمسافات طويلة
خلال أربعين ألف عام  - الكهف القديم
يمر بالمصلى وأنت هناك أو يمكنك
أن تأخذ نزهة لمدة ساعتين عبر
مسارات أخرى ، الجزء الأصعب هو مثل
البنية التحتية لكل كرسي طوال العام
كل الطعام الذي يجب أن يأتي به
التلفريك إذا كان هناك أي شيء حقًا  كبير
وهو  أفي سنستخدم المروحية ،
حصلنا على الكهرباء من التلفريك ،
نحصل على المياه العذبة من
الثلج والمطر في الكهف هو قدر كبير من
الماء وعندما يكون هذا فارغًا ، يتعين علينا
شراء الماء لذلك حصلت  فريق في
خدمة المطبخ ولدي الأشخاص الذين يقومون بجميع
عمليات النقل
[الموسيقى]
وأنا
بالنسبة لي هو
شعور خاص حقًا لأنني أكون هنا هو الجزء المفضل لدي
من اليوم عندما أقف وأحتسي
القهوة  مجرد الجلوس خارج
الشرفة ، يكون الجو هادئًا ويبعث على
الاسترخاء ،
حيث جاء معظم الناس إلى هنا ، فهم سعداء حقًا
لأنهم يشعرون بالسحر لذا
تستيقظ وترى كل شيء ، إنه أمر
لا يُصدق في كل مرة
أبكي فيها.
[موسيقى]